natürlich ist das dann immer recht wird
wenn das jetzt zum beispiel ein junge
wär aber von den haaren her würde ich
sagen das ist ganz klar eine frau und
wie sie heute aussieht da bin ich jetzt
also noch mal von vorne aufnehmen
abbrechen
[Musik]
hey was geht ab bereits bekommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut mir geht es gut
ich bin gestern aus dem urlaub
wiedergekommen bin jetzt in köln in
meinem wunderschönen neuen zimmer musste
mich erst mal ein bisschen ausschlafen
aber heute gibt es natürlich wieder ein
neues video
und zwar habe ich euch gerade auf
install ungefragt das machen wir jetzt
live in diesem video und zwar gab es ja
letztendlich das video von mir vor der
pubertät versys nach der pubertät
einfach wie man sich verändert hat und
ich habe noch zwei weitere videos dazu
vorbereiten weil eine zuschauer
indischen also fotos von euch und einmal
eine promi edition mit ganz vielen
verschiedenen promi und ich habe euch
auf install gefragt auf was sie mehr
bock habt und wir haben hier jetzt 59
prozent für die promi dischen instagram
alex wie gut also gibt es die
probiotischen ich will eigentlich gar
nicht angelaufen moment natürlich lacht
ja das ist doch nach oben da wenn ihr
die zuschauer schon noch sehen wollt und
wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an
mit dem erst promi und ich bin natürlich
gespannt ob ich die sofort erkenne und
der habe mir als erstes also hier muss
ich schon sofort sagen ich habe absolut
keine ahnung ich kann gerade nicht mal
sagen ob es ein junge oder ein mädchen
ist eigentlich sagen mädchen oder
natürlich ist das eine recht wenn das
jetzt zum beispiel ein junge wär auch
von den haaren her würde ich sagen das
ist ganz klar eine frau und wie sie
heute aussieht da bin ich jetzt also
noch mal von vorne aufnehmen abbrechen
es tut mir jetzt natürlich sehr leid
lieber george clooney falls nur das
video siehst nimmst nicht persönlich
also mal kurz beide fotos hier neben
einer wäre irgend jemand von euch darauf
gekommen dass es sich bei dieser älteste
wirklich für mich vielmehr aus meine
frau das dass george clooney mal war ich
finde da sieht man überhaupt keinen
unterschied aber ist natürlich eine
klasse veränderungen im letzten winter
dazu habe ich auch eine veränderung von
mir gezeigt also schaut euch das gerne
hier noch an gut das machen wir auch
schnell weg wir kommen weiter zum
nächsten promi und zwar ist es diese
junge dame was jetzt hoffentlich eine
junge dame ist aber da bin ich mir jetzt
eigentlich zu 100 prozent sicher nur
hier kann ich auch nicht sagen wer das
ist ich könnte mir gut vorstellen dass
es eine sängerin ist vielleicht ist es
vielleicht ist das schreibt gerne in die
kommentare wenn ihr es wisst vielleicht
ist es
ich habe heute nicht auf den namen genau
taylor swift wollte ich sagen das könnte
sein oder vielleicht auch so diese
selber lassen wobei ich jetzt gar nicht
genau weiß wie die aussehen wir schauen
einfach mal rüber und es katy perry a
stimmt das hätte auch sagen können
wieso bin ich da nicht drauf gekommen
wenn man das jetzt neben dann das sieht
kann man auf jeden fall sagen dass es
eine veränderung gibt die aber nicht so
krass ist wie bei george clooney zum
beispiel leben da sieht man das finde
ich vom gesicht und vor allem vom laufen
her extrem dass es sich hier um dieselbe
person handeln muss ja und die katy
perry war halt echt schon in jungen
jahren auch um bezaubert wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten haar okay das
kann ich sofort sagen wenn man dieses
foto jetzt mal ein bisschen heran so
sieht es aus als wäre das so ein kleiner
verbrecher aber ich glaube das ist sich
erfüllen da bin ich mir eigentlich
ziemlich sicher weil das kann man gar
nicht verwechseln heute sieht er
natürlich noch veränderte aus ich habe
somit zwölf jahren oder so auch mal
dieses high school musical geguckt warum
fragt mich nicht nur dass er diesem
aussehen halt extrem ähnlich noch und
wenn man sich das jetzt mal anschaut das
ist sicher für ich bin ein richtiger
high school musical fan hätte das
gewusst schreibt es in die kommentare
übrigens was ich mich eben gefragt habe
und zwar am gibt es ja bald wieder
zeugnisse habt ihr bock dass ich dazu
noch mal ein paar mache wenn ja dann
schreibt auf jeden fall war hashtag
zeugt ist oder so die kommentare und
schickt mir gerne eure zeugnisse dann zu
so wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
wären hier
ein fußballer der ist wirklich extrem
junge noch auf dem foto ich habe
allerdings seine vermutung einfach weil
es mein lieblingsspieler ist ich lasse
ich mal kurz ein paar sekunden zeit
schreibt man in die kommentare was ihr
denkt 123456 6 ich könnte mir jetzt
eigentlich viele fußballer vorstellen
die früher mal so ausgesehen haben aber
wenn man sich das gesicht anguckt dann
könnte es eigentlich nur ihren will
messi sein und es ist leonel messi
ich finde man sieht es extrem an der
nase und auch am und der mund ist so
klein und messis mund ist halt nicht so
groß wenn man das jetzt jemand genauer
unter die lupe nimmt
ja habe ich gut gelöst sehr gut gemacht
als ich sagte okay es gibt allerdings
noch eine menge mehr und wir gucken
einfach mal wenn wir hier haben okay ich
habe ich das foto an
ich muss jetzt hier sagen ich habe das
glaube ich schon mal auf instagram
gesehen diese veränderungen nur ich weiß
jetzt nicht mehr genau wer es war
es war allerdings echt kann gut sein das
ist lady gaga war ich würde einfach mal
sagen lady gaga nicht so ganz daneben
aber schon daneben taylor swift haben
wir hier ist glaube ich zurzeit die
erfolgreichste musikerin habe ich glaube
ich letztens irgendwo gelesen und das
ist wirklich extrem heftig finde ich
wenn man sich das jetzt auch mal
nebeneinander anschaut
allein die haare machen halt erstmal
krassen unterschied aus und sie war
früher
naja von vom gesicht her fülliger find
ich kann natürlich auch sein dass der
eine oder andere dr
ein bisschen herumgedoktert hat aber man
kann hier finde ich auch sehr gut an der
nase erkennen dass es dieselbe person
ist und natürlich an den augen hier ist
jetzt schminke dabei das bild ist
natürlich ein bisschen moderner das
stechen die farben gleich viel mehr raus
aber es ist ein krasser unterschied und
das ist mal wieder ein gutes beispiel
dafür wie heftig man sich verändern kann
ich bin mal gespannt wie ich so in 20
jahren aus hier meint ihr das wird was
oder
nicht so bei mir gut wir machen weiter
mit dem nächsten
und ich wollte jetzt gerade schon sagen
das ist eine von diesem hotel zack cody
was früher mal auch super rtl lief ich
weiß nicht ob ihr das kennt
wahrscheinlich schon aber jetzt habe ich
noch mal nachgedacht und ich glaube es
ist leonardo dicaprio
das muss er eigentlich sein wer anderes
kann es eigentlich nicht sein wenn man
sich jetzt mal sein aussehen von früher
dann moment wir schauen erst mal ja als
ist leonardo dicaprio wenn man sich das
aus schon früher genauer anschaut hätte
er irgendwie perfekten diese nickelodeon
serien gepasst gibt es eigentlich noch
diesen sender
ich habe das früher einmal geguckt aber
habe auch ewig nichts mehr von ihm
gehört
gut ich hoffe ihr wisst was ich meine
hier ist die veränderung jetzt natürlich
da aber sie ist nicht so heftig wie bei
kellers trifft gerade sein gesicht ist
und irgendwie deutlich fülliger geworden
aber gut so leute so die aufnahme ist
gerade unterbrochen so genau
wir kommen zum nächsten bild und zwar
ist es dieses hier ich weiß es schon ich
bin gespannt ob es auch ist wir haben
hier eine schauspielerin und zwar weiß
ich nicht den namen aber ich weiß ganz
genau welche schauspielerin lässt sich
handelt weil ich jetzt vielleicht der
nächste tipp gerne game of thrones
geguckt habe ich habe schon alle
staffeln durch ich weiß noch wie eine
forderung also wenn ihr wisst wer das
ist schreibt es genau jetzt in die
kommentare ich lass mich wieder fünf
sekunden zeit 12 was ist hier los jetzt
ist die aufnahme schon wieder angehalten
wir haben ja auf jeden fall
sophie aus game of thrones die heißt
dass anfragen habe ich genau
ich habe schon lange nicht mehr geguckt
wenn man jetzt beide bilder
nebeneinander hält oder zeit einmal ganz
klar sehen dass es sich um dieselbe
person handelt damals schon orange oder
fast zumindest und heute auch wenn ich
jetzt gerade mal so schaue ich glaube
ich konnte bei 1 234 leuten schon sagen
wer das ist also jetzt eigentlich ja gar
nicht mal so eine schlechte leistung und
ich würde sagen wir machen einfach mal
schnell weiter mit der nächsten person
und zwar ist das kann ich mir nicht gut
merken aber ich weiß ganz genau wie es
ist okay ich weiß denn haben trotzdem
könnt ihr natürlich mit raten schreibt
gerne schnell wieder in den kommentaren
wäre es dass ich hoffe ich jetzt auch
richtig aber wenn ich mir eigentlich
ziemlich sicher es ist wieder eine
schauspielerin und wir es wünschen
einfach mal schnell rüber und haben hier
da irgendwie fand ich die sich früher
früher sah die finde ich noch
sympathischer aus als heute
also irgendwie sieht die auf diesem bild
sehr spießig auch so aber das liegt
wahrscheinlich auch im bild es ist emma
watson harry potter und die gibt es
sieben teil davon war früher auf jeden
fall einen teil meiner kindheit und
werde jetzt nicht kannte der hat
wirklich was verpasst oder so und ich
würde sagen zum abschluss einen haben
wir noch die sieht irgendwie aus wie das
foto von katy perry vielleicht katy
perry noch mal drei jahre jünger aber
ich denke mal dass dies nicht ist und
hier muss ich jetzt sagen ich habe
absolut keinen plan wie es sein könnte
schreibt es gerne in die kommentare wenn
ihr es wisst könnte vielleicht irgendwie
zu dieser rolle familie gehören die da
jetzt letztes geheiratet haben
oder wann war das gestern glaube ich
oder vorgestern kein plan ich habe es
nicht geklappt und es ist megan fox oder
ist es meine tricks ich meine schon also
da wäre ich im leben nicht aufbekommen
das sind für mich komplett zwei
verschiedene personen naja immerhin hat
sie sich heutzutage mal die augenbraue
zwischen rasiert und spaß man hat uns
weiszumachen dass sie überhaupt den
fotos so aus mega krass ähnlich wie bei
taylor swift das waren jetzt einige
promis die sich verändert haben
ich hoffe das video hat euch unterhalten
und ihr konntet fleißig mit raten
schreibt gerne in die kommentare ob ihr
bock habt ihr auf erstens mal die
zeugnis videos und zweitens das ganze
nochmal mit einer zuschauer dischen ihr
könnt mir natürlich weiterhin auf
instagram alex wie weiß ich da weitere
fotos zukommen lassen von euch aber vor
der pubertät und danach weist wir
schauen uns heuer zeit und ja dann würde
ich sagen genießt das schöne wetter
nicht rausgehen und wir sehen uns morgen
gibt's ein neues video diese woche
kommen jetzt wieder viele coole neue
videos also hat rein aber